THE STRONGEST SECRETARIES OF
STATE WE'VE HAD.
ACCORDING TO NEWS REPORTS,
PASTOR BRONSON IS THAT 19TH
PRISONER -- PERHAPS HOSTAGES THE
RIGHT WORD FREED BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
HERE HE IS PRAYING WITH THE
PRESIDENT AT THE WHITE HOUSE
OVER THE WEEKEND -- TAKE A LOOK.
>> I ASK THAT YOU POUR OUT YOUR
HOLY SPIRIT ON PRESIDENT TRUMP,
YOU GIVE HIM SUPERNATURAL WISDOM
TO ACCOMPLISH ALL THE PLANS YOU
HAVE FOR THIS COUNTRY.
I ASK THAT YOU GET SOME WISDOM
NOT
TO LEAD THIS COUNTRY INTO
RIGHTEOUSNESS.
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW IS
PASTOR BRONSON HIMSELF.
I KNOW HOW MANY WORKED ON YOUR
BEHALF -- YOU ARE HELD FOR 1818
MONTHS AND HAD NO REASON, NO
UNDERSTANDING OF WHY AND WERE
HELD IN A CELL DESIGNED FOR 8
AND THERE WERE 21 PEOPLE.
CORRECT?
>> PART OF THAT GAME IT WAS VERY
CROWDED IN THAT CELL.
IT WAS A VERY DIFFICULT TIME.
I WAS SURPRISED BECAUSE I HAD
NEVER CONSIDERED PRISON AS A
POSSIBILITY AND THE COSTS FOR
THAT.
>> Sean: HOW WERE YOU TREATED?
>> I WAS TREATED WELL BY THE
PRISONERS I WAS WITH.
>> Sean: THEY WERE NOT OF YOUR
FAITH.
>> THEY WEREN'T AND THAT WAS ONE
OF THE DIFFICULT THINGS.
I WAS ISOLATED BY CULTURE AND BY
LANGUAGE BUT ESPECIALLY BY
RELIGION.
IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT TO BE THE
ONLY CHRISTIAN AMONG THEM.
>> Sean: WHEN YOU FOUND OUT
WHAT YOU WERE BEING HELD FOR
WHICH WAS YOUR FAITH, WHAT DID
YOU THINK?
>> WHAT WAS SURPRISING IS THAT
THEY TOLD ME I WAS BEING HELD
FOR TERRORISM AND FOR TRYING TO
OVERTHROW THE GOVERNMENT.
THE TRUTH IS IF WE HAD BEEN
PREACHING JESUS CHRIST -- THAT'S
WHY WE WERE IN TURKEY -- IS TO
SHARE THE GOSPEL OF JESUS CHRIST
WITH TURKS.
WE DID THAT OPENLY AND NEVER HAD
A PROBLEM.
IT WAS VERY SHOCKING TO BE
ACCUSED OF TERRORISM.
>> AND IT CAME DOWN TO YOUR
CHRISTIAN FAITH IN MANY WAYS.
I THOUGHT YOUR PRAYER WAS
EXTRAORDINARILY TOUCHING WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
WHAT WAS YOUR WORST MOMENT?
I CAN IMAGINE WHEN YOU LOSE YOUR
FREEDOM YOU LOSE EVERYTHING
ESPECIALLY IN A FOREIGN COUNTRY,
NOT KNOWING WHY YOU'RE BEING
HELD.
NOT HAVING ANYONE TO SHARE YOUR
FAITH, YOUR VALUES WITH YOU,
WHAT WAS YOUR LOWEST MOMENT?
>> WHEN I WAS ARRESTED AND IT
KEPT GOING ON AND ON, IT SEEMED
THAT THERE WAS NO WAY OUT.
I LOST A LOT OF HOPE.
I BEGAN TO SEE THERE WAS VALUE
IN MY SUFFERING ESPECIALLY AS
TIME WENT ON.
I SAW THAT MANY PEOPLE AROUND
THE WORLD BEGAN PRAYING FOR ME
AND I BEGAN TO SEE --
>> Sean: HOW DID YOU HEAR
ABOUT THAT?
>> MY WIFE, SHE WAS THE ONLY
CONTACT I HAD WITH THE OUTSIDE
WORLD.
SHE COULD VISIT ME FOR ABOUT
HALF AN HOUR EVERY WEEK SPEAKING
ON THE PHONE AND SHE WOULD BRING
ENCOURAGEMENT TO ME AND TELL ME
THAT PEOPLE WERE PRAYING FOR ME.
AS I LEARNED THAT, I BEGAN TO
SEE THAT GOD WAS INVOLVED IN US
AND HE WAS GOING TO DO SOMETHING
WITH MY SUFFERING.
>> Sean: WHY DID YOU SAY IT
AND THIS MORNING THAT I WAS ONE
OF THE MOST HATED MAN IN TURKEY?
>> I WAS ACCUSED OF TRYING TO
OVERTHROW THE GOVERNMENT, OF
BEING ALIGNED WITH THE TERRORIST
MOVEMENT, ALSO BEING PART OF THE
PKK WHICH IS A GUERRILLA TERROR
MOVEMENT.
I WAS PLANED FOR ECONOMIC
PROBLEMS TURKEY HAD.
IF THERE ARE PROBABLY AREN'T TOO
MANY PEOPLE WHO LIKE ME RIGHT
NOW.
>> Sean: LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
MOMENT THAT TOUCHED A LOT OF
PEOPLE, YOU'RE A MAN OF GREAT
FAITH AND OBVIOUSLY A STRONG
CHRISTIAN AND YOU PRAYED FOR THE
PRESIDENT -- LET'S TALK ABOUT
THAT MOMENT.
>> IT'S SOMETHING WE HAD HOPED
TO BE ABLE TO DO.
MY WIFE FOR AT SOME TIME WANTED
TO PRAY SOME VERSES OVER HIM
FROM ISAIAH, JUST ASKING FOR THE
SPIRIT OF GOD TO COME UPON HIM.
BEFORE WE WENT TO MEET HIM, WE
LEARNED WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
VISIT IN THE WHITE HOUSE, WE ASK
GOD TO GIVE A SET OPPORTUNITY TO
PRAY FOR THE PRESIDENT.
IT'S A GREAT PRIVILEGE I THINK
MANY PASTORS WOULD LOVE TO DO I
IT.
OUR PRESIDENT NEEDS PRAYER.
>> Sean: WE ARE GLAD YOU'RE
HOME, IT WAS A VERY TOUCHING
MOMENT.
I THINK ALL OF US COULD USE MORE
GOD IN OUR LIVES AND I THINK YOU
IMPACT A LOT OF PEOPLE, WELCOME
HOME, WERE GLAD TO HAVE YOU BAC
BACK.
>> I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR